the u.s is quickly approaching 50
million covet cases since the virus
first appeared almost two years ago the
omicron variant now reported in at least
20 states is adding new cases to that
total this morning pfizer said an
initial study shows a booster shot of
its vaccine can neutralize the omicron
strain other data indicate it could
cause less severe illness and other
variants but there is still so much we
don't know and that is why cbs news
medical contributor dr dave david agus
is here to help sort it out let's start
with that breaking news from pfizer that
we that we just got this morning as we
were going on the air so they say the
booster is is a way to go does that mean
if you have two vaccines that you're not
protected when it comes to omicron yeah
so there's an initial study out of south
africa and with their scientists there
and now with pfizer what they're showing
is that two shots isn't enough and with
two shots you can get significant
breakthrough and you lose so many
antibodies that it's not enough to
protect you the good is is that three
shots is you get a 25-fold increase in
antibodies and you retain the spots on
the t cells that attack the virus so
that's really positive news that it can
blunt the infection no hospitalizations
and hopefully no serious illness with
those boosters and we're seeing booster
numbers go up in the united states
every day more and more so omicron is
pushing people to get in line and get
that booster but david how dangerous is
omicron omicron it seems the initial
things are showing that it's highly
transmissible but it's not as deadly is
that true
the answer is we just don't know and i
know that gets you upset whenever i see
three weeks you guys have been saying
we're we're waiting for the data waiting
for the data waiting and when i say you
guys i mean you expert people it's us
guys yes how much longer do we have to
wait to get the data so we're going to
have to wait probably another two weeks
and what the data are showing now is
that in south africa it probably is a
milder variant but it's about twice as
contagious so if it's half
as aggressive and twice as contagious
that means that you're going to get
significant numbers of hospitalizations
especially here and what we don't know
is if those people that have broken
through in south africa many of them may
have had prior covet and others and had
some protection so we really don't know
with the data from denmark in the united
kingdom which have very similar medical
systems to ours and are very transparent
with their data are going to come due to
the next seven to ten days and we will
know a lot more um i know it's
frustrating for everybody in this
country but we know it is remarkably
infectious and we know it is causing
hospitalizations yeah especially there
are more hospitalizations in younger
kids than we've seen with the other
variants so it is worrisome just not how
worrisome we don't know yet but i think
you need to give us some numbers to say
we may be done with cove but covet is
not done with us this is still a real
problem here oh yeah i mean we have
numbers fatigued over a hundred thousand
new cases a day 1200 deaths yesterday in
the united states and we're averaging
above a thousand deaths a day those are
a thousand people friends relatives
family members that have lost their life
a day here in the united states from the
delta variant that's not even the new
omicron variant and how should we move
in the world christmas is now this is
the 8th 25th okay 17 days away so how
should we move in the world my barometer
is going to an event if you have to i
always ask the covert protocols do you
have to have tested before you come and
do you have the vaccine now i'm going to
ask for the booster christmas holidays
what should people do when they're
traveling about what's the rules so
omicron's going to start peaking here in
january so we're going to have cases
over the next couple weeks but it's not
going to become dominant till january
but what i can tell you now is that the
current travel is relatively low risk
right the air on the airplane every four
minutes is filtered with a hepa filter
that takes that virus and we've all
gotten used to traveling with mass on
you follow the regulations i think
you're going to be safe so traveling
over the holidays is going to be okay
the key thing is we have home testing
and i know you say you think those are
relationships you always give me this
look when i say that and i know that
look and yes i do think they're reliable
to say over the next six hours when
you're at the event that you're not
going to be contagious to others it's
not saying don't you have a low level of
virus within you it's saying do you have
enough virus to be contagious and
they're very good and i think they're
very important and they're accessible to
everybody in the country you can go
online and get them go to your pharmacy
and get them it's accessible and it's
affordable and it provides protection
all right wear your mask on the plane
and remember to take it off when you go
to drink i did it the other day and it
was all in my lap you forget you have it
on
i've done that with two o's several
times all right but wear your mask get
that booster all right yes definitely
get the booster david thank you good to
see you and by the way david agus what
are you doing tonight david agus i am
going to be on the stephen colbert show
i am scared but excited
you'll be all right you don't want to
miss